die deutsche außenministerin ihr
russischer amtskollege sergej lavrov
beide trennen 30 jahre aber auch noch
ein bisschen mehr als diese jahreszahl
und wenn wir das gesicht von frau bär
box schauen dann müssen wir gar nicht
mehr viel dazu sagen das war
an spannung pur
herr lavrov gilt als ein schwieriges
gegenüber sehr erfahren verschiedene
male bei den vereinten nationen für sein
land aktiv gewesen als
botschafter und als ständiger vertreter
jetzt hören wir ein
ich höre gerade dass dies sozusagen erst
einmal das opening ist und noch nicht
die eigentliche pressekonferenz das
heißt es gibt hier aber meine
konsekutive übersetzung die nutzen wir
einfach
wir erfreuen möchten uns auf einen
konstruktiven dialog
wollen mit der neuen deutschen
bundesregierung und hier sind wir darauf
war eingestellt die sich in unserem
dialog angehäuften probleme zu lösen wie
rasante auch für einen guten austausch
mit zu allen mitgliedern der neuen
deutschen bundesregierung
eingestellte und die hoffen sie hat dass
sich dieser dialog auf die gleichheit
auf den gegenseitigen respekt und die
berücksichtigung der interessen der
jeweils anderen stützen wird
was waren
aber stellte
seinen 100
ich danke ihnen herzlich für das
schreiben vom 18 januar ich begleiter
dieses zu schreiben positiv und zwar
möchte die these die aussage
unterstreichen die sich auch in diesem
schreiben findet und zwar die aussage
über die historischen verbindungen
zwischen deutschland und russland und
über die gemeinsame verantwortung das
ist natürlich sehr gut und förderlich
für unser bilaterales verhältnis von
claudia plädieren auch dafür ich teile
voll und ganz ihrer einstellung batu
danke
vielen dank schönen guten tag auch von
meiner seite ich freue mich sehr heute
als neue außenministerin zum ersten mal
bei ihnen zu besuch zu sein daher nach
unserem telefonat herzlichen dank für
die einladung
weil ich euch lieber drehe jetzt so
passiert
sehe ich hier auf den gratis
studieren ab ministerin
die brieftasche telefon
die zweite liga skimaske
mit meiner reise möchte ich deutlich
machen dass die beziehung zu russland
der neuen deutschen bundesregierung und
auch mir persönlich sehr wichtig sind es
gibt keine alternative zu stabilen
beziehungen zwischen moskau und berlin
und daran möchte ich weiterhin arbeiten
und spreche ich hier auch im namen der
gesamten deutsche bundesregierung
hat ihre befriedigung visite bagnasco
waschmaschine
ratifikation federer break ist zwar
relativ
stabil
ich weiß um die tiefe historische
dimension der beziehungen zwischen
unserer beiden länder und deswegen war
es mir wichtig heute während meines
ersten besuches bei ihnen hier in moskau
ein kranz am grab des unbekannten
soldaten nieder zu legen die historische
tiefe auch der historische schmerz
zwischen unseren beiden ländern ist
immer auch auftrag für
politik der gegenwart und für zukünftige
generationen und für die versöhnung nach
dem schrecken der nazi diktatur bleiben
wir den menschen in russland auf ewig
dankbar
group wiener städtische cia sehen ihr
studium nach ihm ist the social media
publishing erst nach einigen blätter vor
stoffmaske wasserski 200 g
data group
primär ging mit den us investoren im in
china
wichtig ist mir so wie sie auch
unterstrichen haben dass wir heute in
ruhe und mit zeit über die ganze breite
von bilateralen und internationalen
themen sprechen themen wo wir gemeinsam
unsere beziehungen verstärken können ich
hatte gestern auch gespräche bereits zum
thema wasserstoff aber auch themen die
unserer freundschaft in diesen tagen
belasten
wolle durch zwei junge pläne in die tat
um und das training absolut respektlos
tarot
mächtige maschine
fc mutiger
sie wurden ja mal wurde am
absolutistischen matura
brasilianische sänger shane
in dem zusammenhang freue ich mich auf
einen ehrlichen offenen austausch und
danke nochmal für die einladung zum
heutigen gespräch
du bringst die
kritik ihres
engagements co
da gehen die mikrofone langsam wieder
aus und auch die kameras bewegen sich
wieder aber das war ein interessanter
start für dieses gespräch in moskau das
für zehn uhr terminiert war und mit
einer stunde dauer möglicherweise etwas
länger frau baerbock sagte gerade ich
freue mich dass wir viel zeit haben
ausführlich zu reden ausführlich regen
können wir jetzt auch mit professor
andreas heinemann grüder
politikwissenschaftler an der
universität bonn herr professor
heinemann grüder blick in die gesichter
ist immer schwer wir können jetzt
sozusagen nicht dort reinlesen aber wie
schwer wird das heute für frau baerbock
in dieses gespräch zu gehen
lawo testen das die frau berbalk ein
schwergewicht oder ein leichtgewicht
er wird auch sich fragen wird sie in der
kontinuität von merkel operieren oder
wird es eine neue grüne außenpolitik
geben er wird versuchen rauszubekommen
ist sie koch oder kellner das ist
eigentlich das kanzleramt für die
russlandpolitik zuständig oder das
auswärtige amt
wird es von deutschland irgendwelchen
neuen vorschläge geben die über den
status quo hinaus gehen und das
stichwort wasserstoff wurde hier schon
angesprochen das heißt also wird das zu
einem neuen schwerpunkt auch der
deutschen außen- und wirtschaftspolitik
gegen russland das heißt klimawandel
energiewende zusammen mit russland das
heißt will man eigentlich in die
überwindung des russischen pedro staates
auch von deutscher seite mit investieren
das heißt jenseits des aktuell sehr hoch
eskalierten konfliktes also da sind
viele punkte die abzuklopfen sind der
chef der münchner sicherheitskonferenz
wolfgang ischinger hatte gestern noch
einmal in einem interview erklärt dass
es auf jeden fall immer nützlich und
wertvoll sei mit herrn darauf zu
sprechen und ihm auch zuzuhören das wird
heute wahrscheinlich auch durchaus neben
den antworten die sie liefern muss ein
wichtiger punkt sein sie haben etwas
angesprochen was frau war gerade noch in
ihrem eingangsstatement mit betont hatte
dass sie für die gesamte bundesregierung
spricht dennoch kann man sozusagen ein
ganz kleines fragezeichen setzen eine
der ersten amtshandlungen des neuen
kanzlers scholz war den politischen
direktor des auswärtigen amtes hat
blödtner direkt zurückzuziehen und
rüberzuziehen ins kanzleramt als seinen
außenpolitischen berater dürfen wir also
das als beleg dafür deuten dass
außenpolitik
maßgeblich auch im kanzleramt mit
verantwortet wird die signale wurden
relativ früh gesendet auch von dem spd
fraktionsvorsitzenden mützenich also
großer streitpunkt zwischen den grünen
und der spd war natürlich nord stream
zwei die pipeline durch die ostsee
wo die grünen immer gefordert haben die
soll gestoppt werden und sie wäre
eigentlich auch weder klima noch
energiepolitisch notwendig und da das
kanzleramt die alte position von merkel
vertreten das ist eine wirtschafts frage
hat wirtschaft also keine kein junktim
hier die grünen haben das jetzt auch
nicht weiter verfolgt und habe nur
gesagt im falle eines krieges
um die ukraine eines angriffs russlands
auf die ukraine könnten astrium 2 wieder
auf den tisch kommen insofern haben die
russen jetzt erstmal eigentlich grund
für entspannung weil
man die zensierung verfahren gibt
einlaufen das aber jetzt keine blockade
von seiten der bundesregierung dass es
erst mal schon die gute botschaft aus
sicht russlands ja genau das steht nur
und holt es kann durchaus noch diese
sozusagen aktivierungs genehmigungen
dann geben so dass es in betrieb gehen
kann formell ist das sozusagen soweit
das in betrieb gehen könnte das bedeutet
auch dass frau berbalk überhaupt keine
vollen hände hat was irgend eine
drohkulisse angeht und das wird
natürlich ihren status jetzt und ihren
stand etwas schwerer machen was wie
würden sie sich denn sozusagen
aufstellen müssen damit sie es geschickt
anstellt und damit sie sie haben das
eingangs erwähnt herr lawrow wird
austesten ob sie ein leicht oder ein
schwergewicht ist was muss ich tun damit
er den eindruck hatte sie ist ein
schwergewicht
es gibt ja wie ich schon erwähnte diese
extrem festgefahrene stagnierende
situation um den dort basteln der
ukraine und da wäre jetzt die frage wird
eine vorstellung entwickelt wo wollen
wir eigentlich am ende legislaturperiode
sein das heißt wollen wir grenzöffnungen
haben grenzübergangs punkte haben wollen
wir die kommunikation zwischen dem don
bass und der ukraine erleichtern was
können wir da zu tun dass weniger
waffenstillstand verletzungen
stattfinden das heißt können wir
konkrete probleme miteinander lösen und
welche aktive vermittlerrolle will
deutschland eigentlich in so einem
konflikt spielen in der vergangenheit
hatte sich stark auf die seite des
ukrainischen präsidenten paul schinke
und dann seelands gestellt das heißt
also eigentlich auch keine unabhängige
vermittler rolle gespielt das wird die
frage sein will muss deutschland sich
hier sich hier engagieren und das zweite
ist meine kanzlerin merkel hatte nach
dem georgien krieg 2008
russland zugesagt es gibt unter meiner
kanzlerschaft keine nato erweiterung um
postsowjetischen staaten das wird eine
frage von labors seien
gilt diese zusage informell weiter das
heißt also wird die grüne
außenministerin sich dafür einsetzen
dass die ukraine doch nato-mitglied wird
vielleicht auch irgendwann georgien oder
bestenfalls status von finnland und
schweden eine antwort finden könnte
heute auch gelingt zwischen herrn
stoltenberg und herrn scholz in berlin
die sich später am tag treffen danke für
diese erste runde professor andreas
heinemann grüder politikwissenschaftler
universität bonn danke ihnen